for most Android apps it's simple to let
services and intense get handled on the
UI thread but as you know that's not
always ideal because you want that
thread to be free for rendering work my
name is Colt McAnlis and with the help
of a handy intent service class getting
this work off the UI thread is a breeze
but let's recap say you want to respond
to an intent but know the work is going
to take a while you don't want that work
running on the UI thread because it
should be busy doing rendering work the
solution here is to receive the intent
on the main thread and then push a work
packet off to some other thread and
you've got a lot of options to do this
for example async task is useful when
the work will result in a UI update but
doesn't really help you if your apps in
the background and there's no UI to
service a handler thread might be better
if the work is going to take a long time
but while you're not receiving intense
this thread is just sitting around
taking up resources but there's a third
option that makes things a little easier
for you intent services at its core an
intent service is kind of a hybrid
between a service class and a handler
thread see it extends the service class
but internally creates a new handler
thread which deals with all of the
intents as they come in
basically it wraps all the moving of
your intent responses to another thread
on your behalf and because intent
services are also services you get their
benefits as well now for example you can
use alarms to schedule repeated work to
happen at regular intervals like
refreshing some social feed updating
cached images or logging analytics and
of course there's a few performance
caveats that you need to be aware of
firstly the handler thread processes
work from a work queue this means that
if a task is going to take a long time
to complete it'll block the other queued
up intense secondly most of the time
when folks talk about intent services
they use some form of broadcast receiver
to communicate results back to the main
thread and update the UI which is fine
but there might be a more performant way
to do the same thing because delivering
messages via intense involves inter
process communication and ultimately
talking to the activity manager so you
could use local broadcast manager to
avoid that work or you could just use
the run on UI thread method after the
work is completed to push a block of
work into the UI threads hand
now besides just being a convenient way
to get intent work on to a thread
intentservice also has the benefit of
making your app a little less likely to
be killed by the system you have to
remember the applications without
foreground activities are more likely to
be killed than ones that have a
foreground activity but when you've got
an intent service running it puts your
app in the middle of these two states a
more killable than an app of the
foreground activity but less killable
than a background app without all those
things and probably most important is
not to confuse intent services with
other types of threaded helper classes
while intent services are pretty
powerful they aren't a general-purpose
threading solution so make sure you
check out the other containers to see
which one fits your particular needs see
this is what performance is all about
understanding the nuances and caveats to
make the best decisions for your
codebase which is why you should check
out the rest of the Android performance
patterns videos and don't forget to join
the Google+ community to ask great
questions to other great developers so
keep calm profile your code and always
remember perf matters